[Musique]
quoi de plus réconfortant que l'odeur et
le goût du Becken au petit déjeuner mais
cette charcuterie peut aussi couper
l'appétit avec sa mauvaise réputation
gras salés cher et contenant les
nitrites c'est vraiment intéressant lui
j'ai demandé à la nutritionniste F crepo
doit-on se méfier du bacon
quelle grande question écoute il y a pas
aucun aliment pour lequel on doit se
méfier il y a pas d'interdit quand je
mange du bacon je le mange parce que
c'est gras n'est-ce pas on se dit pas
assez ma source de protéines donc c'est
pas un aliment qu'on va vouloir avoir
son assiette tout le temps
de gros sel et nitrite c'est trois
choses qu'on retrouve au niveau du bacon
il faut s'entendre que c'est avec
modération que tout fonctionne
Alexandre Robin est bouché éleveur de
porc et copropriétaire de la ferme
familiale gasport il prépare du bacon
tranché avec le flan cette partie située
de l'épaule à la cuisse de porc dans
notre cas nous on cuit notre bacon
beaucoup plus élevé puis on le tranche
plus épais on met peu de nitrite mais on
en met quand même trop pas manger
augmente les risques d'avoir le cancer
en 2015 l'OMS avait inscrit les
charcuteries sur les listes des produits
cancérogènes les coupables les nitrites
nouvelles plus récentes pour les
amateurs de bacon et de charcuterie en
juillet 2022 lancès l'Agence nationale
de sécurité sanitaire de France
l'équivalent de l'Agence canadienne
d'inspection des aliments publiait une
méta-analyse confirmant un lien entre le
risque de cancer du côlon et
l'exposition au nid traités au nitrate
pour jeter un éclairage sur cette
nouvelle étude je suis allé rencontrer
Nicolas bourdenave professeur à
l'Université d'Ottawa l'OMS a déterminé
que par exemple pour la consommation de
charcuterie au-delà de 50 g par jour on
augmente de 20% le chances les chances
d'apparition de cancer colorectal à
terme en fait les nitrites réagissent en
particulier avec le fer et avec avec des
protéines pour donner ses composés voilà
qui sont qui sont associés au cancer
est-ce que c'est nécessaire qu'on les
ajoute alors les nitrites et les
nitrates ils ont deux fonctions en
particulier
la première à la base c'est une fonction
de conservation c'est pour éviter la
croissance de certaines bactéries
pathogènes qui à la base de la maladie
qui s'appelle le botulisme et la
deuxième fonction c'est celle de donner
une couleur rosée à la viande il y a un
minimum de nitrites nitrates à avoir
pour pouvoir porter ce nombre de
charcuteries ou de viande saumurer c'est
à peu près 100 mg par K programme de
produits et il faut pas dépasser 200 mg
par kilogramme le problème c'est dans la
consommation chronique et répéter
régulière
et attention si on voit de plus en plus
les mentions sans nitrites poudre de
céleri ou encore nitrite naturel sur les
emballages de Becken il faut lire les
petits caractères certaines entreprises
avisent leur clientèle que par sa nature
la poudre de céleri contient des
nitrites c'est une alternative qui
paraît intéressante du point de vue de
l'image pour les consommateurs ils ont
l'impression qu'on leur donne quelque
chose de naturel et donc de plus sain
dans le monde végétal par contre ce sont
surtout des nitrates qu'on trouve
inoffensifs cela les nitrates retrouve
dans beaucoup de légumes ou de salades
dans les épinards de la betterave ou le
céleri justement sont riches en nitrates
et donc on peut s'en servir comme
remplacement par la fermentation
l'industrie transforme ces nitrates en
nitrites est-ce qu'un jour on pourrait
voir du bacon sans nitrite pour
l'instant du point de vue réglementaire
c'est pas possible c'est que les
nitrites et les linestrad font partie du
standard d'identité des charcuteries
donc ça voudrait dire que le
consommateur accepte de consommer de la
viande qui n'a pas l'aspect aspect
habituel même si le goût lui en fait
n'est pas affecté je pourrais faire une
summer sans nitrite par contre c'est sûr
que si on va sur une durée de vie mais
on prend pas offrir une durée de vie de
30 jours tu vas faire un 5-6 jours
au Canada on se mur généralement le
bacon par injection chez Gaspor se
mélangent et fait maison
de l'ail baigner poivre différentes
saveurs qu'on fait juste infuser un peu
comme un thé on laisse reposer avec le
sel sucre un peu de nitrite et après on
se retrouve à l'injecté quand il rendu
froid le lendemain puis on va l'amener
dans un fumoir au bout des rats
pour qui doit surveiller sa consommation
de sodium la négation réduit en selle le
33 à 50% peut être attrayante cependant
dans les charcuteries comme le bacon on
ajoute aussi d'autres sources de sodium
que le sel comme par exemple ici dans la
liste d'ingrédients on va phosphate de
sodium érythorbate de sodium nitrite de
sodium qui peuvent contribuer aussi un
peu à l'apport en sodium en fait c'est
l'histoire de réduction de l'eau et du
Grot qui est perdu à la cuisson qui fait
en sorte que finalement concentrer dans
le bacon cuit on a à peu près le même
niveau de sodium comme quoi des fois les
tout ce qui est marketing alimentaire
est un peu trompeur le béquilles n'en
fait partie d'ailleurs certaines marques
d'entrée de gamme vous font payer très
cher pour du gras
on fait le calcul du prix une fois cuit
avec le bacon et l'eau partie ça revient
hyper cher
en un peu plus d'une décennie le prix du
bacon a pratiquement doublé atteignant
20 à 25 dollars le kilo puis ça équivaut
environ 65 dollars le kilogramme
pratiquement autant que le filet mignon
aujourd'hui vous devrez débourser entre
100 et 130 dollars le kilogramme pour la
version précuite c'est toujours une
question de bénéfice on cherche toujours
économiser du temps mais on met un peu
de côté tout ce qui est l'aspect cuisine
prendre le temps connaître les aliments
savoir qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans mon
assiette c'est quand on dit que le
véhicule on veut pas en avoir à tous les
jours à son assiette mais que j'ai mon
Bécu une précuit facile à mettre dans
mes dans mes sandwichs à tous les jours
peut-être que ça devient un peu plus
facile d'en avoir très souvent puis
qu'au final il y a un impact sur ma
santé à long terme
santé Canada recommande les portions
hebdomadaires suggérées par l'OMS soit 3
portions de 100 g par semaine de viande
rouge cuite ou de charcuterie
sachant qu'une tranche de bacon est
d'environ 5 g il faudra réserver cette
gâterie pour le brunch du samedi si vous
avez envie de manger du bacon fais juste
à manger moins de tranches puis prendre
celui que vous préférez au goût on fait
pas d'habits tout simplement
l'épicerie c'est aussi demandé d'où
proviennent les flancs de porc utilisé
pour faire le bacon un email aimé pelif
les deux plus importants fabricants de
bacon au Canada nous assurent que la
matière première est canadienne sauf en
cas de demande exceptionnelle mais pour
le livre nous précise que cette année
seulement 4% du bacon étaient fabriqués
avec des flancs de porc importer des
États-Unis dans tous les cas l'étiquette
mentionne tout de même produit fabriqué
au Canada